et si ce caillou était conscient
[Musique]
papa selon certains philosophes ce
caillou est conscient vous êtes
conscient je suis consciente cette
banane est conscient cette statue de
cire taille réelle d'elvis et consciente
ce roseau et pensant cet homme est
complètement inconscient la conscience
est partout en toutes choses
je pense que ma famille aussi qu'il a
compté 38 en france bien d'autres
commerces et la théorie philosophique
qui défend cette hypothèse s'appelle le
pan psychisme de grecs pas qui veut dire
flûte et psychisme le cassoulet cette
théorie est défendue par une minorité de
philosophes mais je suis tombé dessus il
ya pas longtemps et ça m'a interpellé du
coup je me suis documenté et voilà
moralité n'ouvrait jamais d'eux et pour
ces gens là donc tout est conscient tout
si je peux me permettre d'interrompre
bien cordialement ça veut dire quoi
conscient ici bas j'ai passé trivial
être conscient ça peut renvoyer à des
capacités cognitives comme être attentif
à soi même et se représenter ses propres
états interne et être capable de les
rapporter du genre si tu me présente un
poster des beach boys peut dire ah tiens
voilà un poster des beach boys ma foi je
suis présentement en train de regarder
un poster du beach boys
c'est fou on parle de conscience d'accès
et de conscience de soi pour désigner ce
type de capacités cognitives et
j'imagine que les psychismes ne
considère pas que les cailloux sont
conscients en ce sens là car
manifestement ils n'ont pas de capacités
cognitives du tout face vois que tu as
jamais vu un pyroxène réseau dans un
sudoku en fait la conscience dont
parlent les pentes sims c'est la
conscience phénoménal c'est l'effet que
ça fait d'être moins d'être voix ou toit
où tous ceux qui le veulent ou lui ou
elle où tous ceux qui sont seuls à
si tu m'as observe attentivement ou si
tu te sert d'outil tu peux savoir que
j'ai une hauteur de 1 mètre 20 une masse
de 3 tonnes 12 une charge électrique nul
et une belle collection du magazine
challenge et personne à part moi ne sait
à quoi je pense en ce moment que je une
présentement une forte odeur de harengs
que j'ai mal aux vacuum postérieur droit
que je flippe un petit peu que tu
commences à me poser des questions sur
personne en bref mon ressenti puisque ce
que ça fait d'être moi pour parler avec
des mots intelligence et la dimension
purement subjective et qualitative de
l'expérience consciente le ressenti
intérieur le vécu en première personne
de l'intérieur quel effet ça fait d'être
une youtube 2 à succès aussi priante que
modeste une pipistrelle ou masseurs
fiona dauphins ou un caillou les
philosophes disent les philosophes
disent aussi les qualia ça fait très
chic non ça c'est une espèce de
marsupial arboricole herbivore endémique
d'australie est le seul représentant
encore vivants de la famille des phases
collaert idée on s'instruit tout ce que
tu peux me passer il est la conscience
phénoménal donc figurez vous que c'est
pas facile à étudier parce que ces
aspects de l'expérience reste
nécessairement privé et incommunicable
oui j'utilise ce genre demandé je peux
connaître que ma propre expérience en
première personne à l'instant présent il
est impossible pour moi de vérifier si
si toi nous les gens qui regardent cette
vidéo là bonjour vous avez aussi une
conscience phénoménal tu auras beau me
dire ah bah oui dis donc je vois yves le
caillou c'est vraiment au vu du furet
nouveau incroyable ça me montre
seulement que tu as une conscience
d'accès tu me montres tes capacités
cognitives c'est super mais c'est parce
que je veux savoir en vente pour savoir
si tu fais vraiment l'expérience
subjective de voir ce caillou comme moi
je le vois pour savoir si tu as une
conscience phénoménal le seul moyen ce
serait que je fasse cette expérience à
ta place en première personne de
l'intérieur quoi tu veux venir à
l'intérieur de moi balances ton port et
pour en revenir au pape sy schisme donc
cette théorie revient à attribuer une
dimension intérieure de ce type là pas
seulement aux objets humanoïdes comme
comme vous et moi mais a absolument tout
chose dans l'univers même celles qui
n'ont pas de capacité cognitive la
conscience phénoménal serait juste un
truc fondamentale qui se manifeste
partout jusque dans la moindre particule
élémentaire chaque atome chaque
électrons chaque breton chaque neutre on
aurait une dimension intérieure
subjective d'equalia il y aurait un
effet que ça fait d'être un proton
d'être un caillou d'être la terre
philippe geluck en peau de pétunias ou
un trombone prenez y vivent à une masse
une charge électrique nul et la truffe
humide si on le lâche il tombe vers le
sol si les magnetic hill sera attiré par
un aimant ses caractéristiques physiques
décrivent le comportement de l'objet
d'un point de vue extérieur un peu comme
moi si tu me présente une motte de
beurre je vais être attirés vers
loïc quoi second le beurre et parce que
je suis une êtres humaines vous supposez
que j'ai un effet que ça fait d'être
attiré par le beurre et parce que
l'époque si schiste suppose c'est la
même chose pour yves le cas il ya en lui
un point de vue intérieure un effet que
ça fait d'être attiré par un aimant
alors vive qu'est ce que ça te fait
d'être attiré par un aimant bon une fois
de plus il ne me répondra pas et la
science non plus ne nous permet pas de
répondre à cette question ce que fait la
science c'est de décrire un comportement
d'essayer de prédire la trajectoire
corps à yves si je lançant là à
l'intersection de cette trajectoire avec
le corps de la femme a dû tarn iran donc
la science nous décrit la matière depuis
l'extérieur mais peau de buffle sur sa
vie intérieure comme le dit le
philosophe philippe gault un des porte
étendards du pacifique
tout ce que nous tirons des sciences
physiques c'est cette structure
abstraites en noir et blanc on doit
remplir de nature intrinsèque d'une
manière ou d'une autre on sait comment
colorier une de ces cases le cerveau des
organismes vivants et colorié de
conscience et le reste l'option la plus
simple élégante est censé serait de
colorier le reste du canevas de la
réalité de la même couleur la couleur de
la conscience un commentaire thibault ce
passage éclair sur la principale
motivation du paon psychisme ce serait
justifié par une sorte de principe
d'économie
l'idée sous jacente c'est que je suis
absolument certain d'une chose c'est
qu'il y ait au moins une chose ayant une
conscience prix nominal dans le monde
physique moi même vu que j ai
directement accès et si je suis
conscient en ce sens c'est probablement
lié à mon cerveau ou à mon organisme de
façon générale la grande question le
problème difficile de la conscience
comme disait le philosophe c'est de
savoir comment expliquer ces propriétés
phénoménal dans un cadre matérialiste le
matérialisme c'est quand on a besoin de
posséder des objets pour être heureux
comme une lampe de chevet de style ou un
semainier luigi une desserte en ronce
dacca alors nous un cadre matérialiste
ça veut juste dire qu'on ne reconnaît qu
des objets et des propriétés physiques
et expliquer la conscience minimale dans
ce cadre ça pose des problèmes qui
semblent franchement insolite max la
menace est un petit enfant d'abord parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de raisons pour
lesquelles réduire les propriétés
phénoménal a des propriétés physiques
semblent condamnés d'avancé vu que les
premières sont des trucs subjectif privé
incommunicable tout ça tout ça et
ensuite parce que poser un critère pour
délimiter quel organisme quelle portion
du monde physique dispose de conscience
phénoménale et lesquels n'en disposent
pas ça a toujours des conséquences plus
ou moins absurde
arbitre est déplaisante donc on a un
problème général d'explication comment
expliquer la conscience phénoménal dans
un cadre matérialiste et un problème
plus particulier de délimitation où se
situe la limite entre ce qu'il ya une
consoeur phénoménale et ce qu'il en a
pas est ce qui est bien avec le
psychisme c'est que c'est une solution
économe à ces deux problèmes à la fois
d'une part on va dire que les aspects
fenomeno sont justes fondamentaux
irréductible à quoi que ce soit d'autre
donc ça se passe d'explication mais du
coup on n'est plus dans un cadre
matérialiste on admet que les objets les
propriétés physiques ne puisse pas tout
ce qu'il y a dans le monde il y a des
aspects non physique et d'autre part vu
que la phénoménale ite est un aspect
fondamental de la réalité est que tracer
une limite entre ce qu'il y a une
conscience phénoménale et ce qui n'en a
pas' semblera toujours arbitraire autant
ne pas tracer du tout de limites on
admettra juste que toute chose a des
propriétés phénoménal seront plus ou
moins riches s'est étendu selon la
complexité de la chose mais il n'y aura
jamais qu'une différence de degré de
conscience entre le caillou et la
valentine et non une différence de
nature le caillou et très peu conscients
et la valentine est plutôt pas mal
consciente ça va au demeurant ce genre
d'idées se trouvait déjà chez line si
vous voulez tout savoir avec ces
histoires de monado perception plus ou
moins confuse ou clair mais ce serait un
peu long à expliquer bon c'est pas comme
si c'était ma vidéo ça va le name
dropping your name no priou a le droit
que considère que sa somme pour le dire
dans les termes de golf puisque je vois
à l'intérieur de moi une couleur dont
aucune explication physique ne peut
rendre compte le plus simple et élégant
pour en rendre compte ce serait de dire
que cette couleur est juste fondamental
c'est un aspect non physique du monde et
que toute chose à l'intérieur
couleur similaire à différentes google
pour les planchistes un caillou ce
serait juste un tas de briques de
conscience mais comme le monsieur flo
l'a dit c'est pas pour autant qu'il
aurait le même degré de conscience que
nous ce caillou et oui nous les animaux
on aura un truc en plus chez nous ces
formes élémentaires de conscience se
combinerait entre elles pour donner les
formes incroyablement complexe qu'on
connaît et qui nous permettent
d'élaborer des raisonnements vachement
élaboré comme rush frérot j'ai grave
envie d'un kebab
bon alors si on en croit goff et ses
comparses toute chose serait consciente
même les trucs mort simplement quand on
est fiona y aurait plus d'interactions
entre les briques de conscience de notre
corps comme pour le caillou cette girafe
empaillé ou cette discographie complète
de patrick hernandez cela dit le gros
point d'interrogation c'est de savoir
comment on passe d'un tas de petites
conscience élémentaire à une belle et
grosse conscience comme la nôtre je veux
voir ma belle et grosse conscience comme
le dit gough si on empile des lego on
obtiendra une tour de lego
nul besoin d'ajouter aux parties pour
obtenir le tout mais si on empile sent
minuscule esprit conscience est
difficile d'imaginer comment pourra
obtenir autre chose qu'un tas de sang
minuscule esprit conscient isolés les
uns des autres
comment faire pour fusionner ses
minuscules les esprits et en obtenir un
tout unifié aujourd'hui les psys
quinzaine aujourd'hui les pentes si
schiste n'ont pas de solution à ce
problème qu'ils ont baptisé le problème
de la combinaison des gants mais nike
team problèmes mais ils travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour essayer d'y apporter
une réponse
et puis la différence entre ce caillou
et moi c'est que d'après les pompes si
schiste plus la chose est organiquement
complexe lui sa conscience serait
développé oui évidemment en l'humain est
au dessus du responsable bien qu'on est
plus évoluée que les autres trucs sur
terre cela dit c'est vrai qu'on a plus
évolué qu'un caillou vu qu'un caillou ça
évolue pas sauf dans les pokémon vous
demandez peut-être si tout cela est bien
un scientifique au fond cuba importe si
schiste vous dire ouais t'inquiète frère
c'est grave scientifique sa mère parce
que ça s'appuie sur la théorie de
l'information intégrer une formation
payée mais la théorie dominante de la
conscience là les winter wind of
consciousness même que le grand
philosophe de l'esprit gouaille class of
heroes desperate david chalmers le dit
dans son talk lieu un dieu un dieu
et cette théorie oui encore une semble
aller dans le sens du pape sy schisme
effective qu'est ce que tu dit ça
monsieur flou monsieur hors champ ce que
tu pourrais nous donner ta réponse mais
en rappant alors là il a été hissé en
gros une théorie qui postule qu'une
certaine propriété formelle que ses
créateurs a fait fi semeta détermine le
degré de conscience d'un système mais
notez bien que c'est purement formelle
et surtout c'est totalement spéculatifs
rien ne permet de justifier cette
identification de cette valeur fit un
degré de conscience
c'est une job posterai et cette théorie
semble poser des tas de problèmes par
ailleurs par exemple des problèmes
devant les malaxer matic de la théorie
et il semble aussi qu'elle ne colle pas
avec certaines données en effet une
conséquence de la théorie semble être
que cette valeur fille est très sensible
à des perturbations mineures du système
ce qui colle mal avec l'idée que nous
sommes conscients et que notre cerveau
est très plastique justement pas du tout
sensibles à des perturbations mineures
du coup en gros la y ait dit ça sans
être une bien jolie construction
mathématiques mais les seules personnes
qui soutiennent que la ja qui domine
quoi que ce soit dans le champ de la
conscience
ce sont précisément les créateurs de
l'ail haïti ainsi que les pompes si
schiste qui voient en elle une façon
commode de parer leur position d'un
dernier de scientificité
en dehors de cela le verdict des
philosophes et des neuroscientifiques
est plutôt unanimes et pourrait bien se
résumer en un mot
[Musique]
voilà
pour pau pau donc pour en revenir à yves
est ce que c'est un caillou pensant et
ben si on en croit ces hippies de pantxi
schiste a priori peut-être
éventuellement un tout petit peu mais de
toute façon pas assez pour méditer sur
le sens de la vie ni pour résoudre les
mots fléchés du 20 minutes après c'est
mignon mais c'est super chaud à vérifier
une hypothèse pareil de toute façon
parce qu'on est incapable de vérifier si
un truc ou ou un organisme est conscient
ou pas comme on a causé par devers nous
au début de la vidéo
alors donc c'est ça la philo vous
apporter toujours plus de questions mais
jamais de réponse en fait c'est qu'on
apporte parfois plusieurs réponses à une
même question c'est ça qui pose le
problème finalement c'était pas vraiment
dans le champ droit pour ces questions
de conscience phénoménal l'approché la
plus répandue est d'essayer de lui faire
une place tout en restant dans un cadre
matérialiste c'est à dire sans supposer
qu'il y ait autre chose que des objets
et des propriétés physiques même si ça
pose pas mal de problèmes j'en parlais
d'ailleurs avec david louapre dans notre
vidéo sur la conscience d'ailleurs ça
c'était bien comme collab ça c'était
voulu sinon il ya une autre solution
radicale plutôt que de repeindre le
monde aux couleurs de la conscience on
peut juste nier que cette couleur
intérieure existe autrement dit nier
l'existence de ces aspects phénoménaux
de l'expérience c'est la position des
illusionnistes est clairement ça résout
d'un même poule et 2 problème
d'explication et de délimitation de la
conscience phénoménal dont je parlais
tout à l'heure ça résout le problème de
l'explication puisqu'il n'y a plus rien
à expliquer et le problème de la
délimitation vu qu'il n'ya plus rien à
limiter non plus c'est commode
par contre ça crée un autre problème du
type comment se fait-il que nous n'ayons
pas de conscience phénoménal alors que
quand même on dirait bien que on en a
ben oui le fait que je sois pas morte à
l'intérieur c'est pas genre le seul truc
absolument certains dont je puisse être
certaine avec une absolue certitude si
si si j'ai fait une vidéo là-dessus
justement ça s'appelle j'ai mal c'est
très très bien et j'ai aussi une
interview de divisionnisme et c'est pas
le moment où on fait sa plus longue
allée voir sur sa chaîne l'interview de
gérard majax alors petit ressentent
beaucoup alexandra 6,7 rem est un
illusionniste et pantxix schiste sont
vraiment assez proche parce qu'ils
partent du même constat à ça
à savoir qu'on ne peut pas expliquer la
conscience phénoménal dans un cadre
matérialiste la différence c'est qu'ils
n'en tire pas les mêmes conclusions pour
les uns ça veut dire qu'il faut sortir
du cadre matérialiste et admettre que la
conscience phénoménale et partout et
pour les autres ça veut dire qu'elle
n'est nulle part pas même en nous dans
les deux cas ça veut dire quand même
qu'on a plus en commun avec les cailloux
qu'on imagine soit parce que eux aussi
ont cette dimension subjective dont on
pense ce vêtement avec les seuls
dépositaires soit parce qu'on est aussi
vide à l'intérieur
[Musique]
ça veut dire quoi dépositaire donc nous
voilà bien avancés quoi au final
chaque théorie assez trop à combler tu
veux que je combatte est en tout cas le
psychisme et l'illusionnisme ça reste
des théories minoritaire en philosophie
de l'esprit de la théorie dominante
actuellement c'est plutôt le
fonctionnalisme mais c'est un peu long
et chiant explique et vous voulez en
savoir plus allez plutôt voir la superbe
vidéo de david louapre avec aussi
monsieur fils de dentiste diplôme groupe
pense à mon public mineur je vends
souvent la manse public mais neuf alors
on tournait bien
on peut de fait bien que trop les
valeurs républicaines
il entend se faire siffler dans la rue
bassano malfrats c'est un compliment
en fait si vous voulez tout savoir
interdire l'avortement rétablir la banda
c'est un peu ça de toute façon
aujourd'hui en bout
sans transition cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par display oulala mon tout
premier sponsor ça y est j'ai vendu mon
âme vous voyez ces magnifiques posters
et bah c'est moi qui les ai design et et
ouais et vous pouvez les retrouver dès
maintenant sur ma boutique en ligne sur
le site de display it et oui car despite
c'est des posters en métal avec une
impression de qualité supérieure comme
le jambon mais sans la couenne et si
vous n'aimez pas mais design vous n'avez
pas de goût mais vous pouvez trouver
plus de 800 mille autres posters sur
leur site voila il même pour les
géologues c'est pour dire que j'ai fait
une petite sélection de mes préférés si
ça c'est pas prévenant quand même 1 1 1
les impressions sont faites à la demande
livré en quelques jours et les plaques
se fixe très facilement au mur avec un
système d'aimants c'est super facile à
faire et comme ça vous pouvez garder
beaucoup pour d'autres choses plus
utiles comme crucifier des messies en
plus pour chaque post a racheté
displayed plantes en arabe
un arbre a les yeux tu es ma boutique en
ligne voilà vous me direz ce que vous
pensez de mais exclu quand même j'ai
passé un petit peu de temps dessus j'en
suis un peu fier et gardez l'oeil ouvert
puisque je vais en ajouter d'autres au
fur et à mesure et puis si vous voulez
utiliser mon lien affilié en description
c'est très important comme ça vous vous
avez une réduction et moi j'ai de la
thune c'est win win soutenait les
artistes de talent on soutenait les
vidéastes que vous soutenez et offrez
vous des amis puisque selon les pentes
six fils de chacun de ces posters à sa
propre conscience et on sait à quel
point vous êtes seul en ce moment à
bientôt sur dix plaies au final chaque
lauréat fait trois combler ou de vomir
depuis que j'ai offert cette conscience
à ma femme
et merci mille fois monsieur philippe
devenu sur ma chaise inoccupés est allé
voir sur sa chaîne il ya plein de trucs
vachement intelligent pour des gens
cultivés et tout et c'est trop bien
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à un
moment fabuleux
et d'activer la cloche l accent qui
ressort merde c'est parce que j'ai trop
le personnage n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner ci se bidonne derrière d'activer
la cloche je ne veux plus je me défaire
de cet acteur il faut que je pense au
yaourt et n'oubliez pas d'activer la
cloche à cloche à koch abonnez-vous
mofaz but yaourt
abonnez vous au mossad lui et n'oubliez
pas d'activer la cloche coquine
[Musique]